all right we are now live for the August
AMA ask me anything session so this is
the one time of the month that viewers
subscribers supporters fans whoever else
we think that gets to ask me dr. Sadler
questions about various things usually
related to philosophy
sometimes more personal questions I will
mention as we get started that today is
in fact my birthday so I'm happy to be
sharing my early afternoon with all of
you out there in the internet ether and
I'll you know address whatever questions
come up got my coffee here on my desk
you know and hear me moving it around
bit by bit and already we've got a first
happy birthday but I'll just say thanks
ahead of times everybody who's wishing
me a happy birthday I do have to
normally I go a little bit over time
with these but today I've got to finish
up right at the top of the hour because
we're going out for a birthday lunch
with a friend of mine who came in from
out of town who were gonna hang out with
and that'll be a lot of fun and then
it's it's back to work for me as people
are writing questions I'll actually just
tell you a little bit about what's
what's going on so normally I just teach
part-time right as a professor or
lecturer and I you know I do a lot of
other things on the site including all
this this YouTube video work and
podcasting and all that business but
right now what I'm what I'm what I've
got going is for classes for the Fall
I've actually got two at Marquette and
I'm pointing that way because Marquette
is actually about you know depending on
where you got to go on campus 10 to 12
blocks that way and then I have another
class that I'm teaching at my ADD which
is that direction about seven blocks I
interviewed at Milwaukee Area Technical
College
I might be teaching there in the fall my
ad by the way is Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design so it's all Art and
Design students that I'll be teaching
philosophy classes to which is really
cool and then I'm teaching an online
class later in the semester for mayoress
that's on top of the other classes that
I'm developing for the reason I know
Academy all of the talks that I do
stoical week coming up stoical on coming
up various other things in the works
including a workshop later this month
for high school teachers to help them
incorporate philosophy into their
curriculum teach them about ethics but
how to answer questions dealing with
that history of philosophy some things
along those lines all right so let's see
if we got any questions I don't see any
yet a lot of happy birthday messages
which are quite nice all right so we
first starting out with questions we've
got one that starts out very it's a kind
of a loaded question is to lose a
Charlton no he's not he's he does say a
lot of things that probably had he not
already been kind of a famous
philosopher he probably would never have
been published in his lifetime and he so
he got away with a lot of things but I
don't think he's a charlatan he is doing
a interesting project I actually like
reading his history of philosophy works
and I like his some of his essays about
literary criticism I I don't you know I
don't do much with deluzy ends because
they tend to be sort of drink the
kool-aid types of course they're they're
so anti-establishment that they they
wind up becoming their own kind of
establishment but no I think the lose is
a interesting person to spend time with
here's one from Daniel this Hegel's
ideal as a mean even spontaneous actions
get conceptualized what about my muscles
contracting and relaxing while walking
or the seemingly unthought motions of
brushing my teeth no those those are
conceptualized as a matter of fact you
know for Hegel
at any given time whatever dialectic is
advancing it's it's usually only at like
you know one place in in the world or
one region and it doesn't involve
everybody most people from Hegel's
perspective although they are their
subjectivity czar constituted by where
they've wound up in history so we as you
know living in the first world in the
new millennium are in a very different
state than say people in the Renaissance
most people are not really
conceptualizing anything they're living
in the in the realm of feelings and sort
of stray thoughts and what Hegel calls
force telling or representations about
things all right come condottiere oh hey
dr. Sandler should you learn ancient
Greek to learn Plato Aristotle or learn
more about the history philosophy of
that area if you had to choose one or
the other I guess you know if I had to
choose between those two I would say
learning more about the historical
background and philosophy of the era
would be would be helpful it really
depends on why you want to learn the
stuff I mean you know if you want to
learn Aristotle say if you want you know
read the ethics and understand its
relation to the politics and the
rhetoric of the poetics and honestl it
really does help to be able to read the
Greek because the translations often
aren't consistent in how they translate
terms so the same term may be translated
in several different ways in several
different places and so being able to
read the Greek helps with that a lot
right but it's not impossible right and
you know it's quite an investment to
learn Greek so I guess if you had to
pick the trade off I would say you
probably get more bang for your buck out
of learning about the context here's a
question by three by four architecture
have you ever studied Krishnamurti
studied would be a bit too strong of a
term I've read him I haven't I haven't
extensively studied him I haven't put in
the work to study him the way I have
with you know thinkers who I you know
more you could say an expert on right
and I don't really pretend to any
expertise in non-western philosophy
whether it be Indian Chinese or
otherwise but I have you know read him
and I have discussed him in tutorial
sessions of all things with with a few
people so yeah let's see what else we
got here from brewmaster I have a
question you cover many philosophers and
cover them very objectively and don't
seem to inject your opinion into the
teachings what are your personal beliefs
about the things that you teach yeah I
try to keep it as not just objective but
as sort of a simple sympathetic
portrayal as I can impart because my my
goal is primarily before we begin like
critical analysis and argument about
whether somebody's got things right or
wrong I think it's important to get
clear about what it is that they're
actually saying and try to work through
any misunderstandings and things along
those lines
now my own personal beliefs well I've
said this before I'm an eclectic so on
some things you can see I do have
positions pretty well worked out on
other things I'm still sort of you know
I'm not sort of like you know
provisionally until later you know like
some sort of pragmatist or fallibilist
perspective but I I'll say well you know
the Aristotelian they seem to be right
about this but then you know there's
this over here but the Stoics are saying
and then Hegel has this point over here
so I'm always sort of building and and I
and I like the philosophical approaches
that leave room for doing that like the
Aristotelian approach and I would say
the stoic approach does that and I would
say some Christian thinkers do that as
well so I'm I'm you know I kind of mix
and match you could say here's one from
David what do I think about the idea of
Christianity is the historical
foundation for modern Western values
individual rights equality of human
value can you find the same ideas and
stoicism I think the notion of
historical foundation for modern Western
values itself is is kind of a pipe dream
usually what people are referencing that
it's as if they think that like there's
a block of ideas and then those lead to
this over here and so you know somehow
because there's a back history you know
you should you should pledge allegiance
to this stuff over here or like somehow
it goes like wholesale from one to the
other and that's just not the way ideas
trickle down through history there are
some things that the Christianity either
brought on the scene or accentuated and
emphasized that are you know part of our
we could call it modern Western heritage
and you're asking in particular about
lis like you political conceptions and
ethical conceptions can you find some of
the same ideas and stoicism yeah and you
can even find some of the same ideas in
other philosophies as well but sometimes
they don't have the same weight the
other thing to say though is you know
when we think about like the age of
faith if all you do is read some
medieval documents you know like some
histories of monasteries and you find
out that people were all over the map
you know people who are supposed to be
nominally Christian or behaving and very
ways very out of accord with what it is
that you know the the scriptures or
their church was teaching and and
sometimes they would recognize that
sometimes they wouldn't so it's it's a
bit more murky and complex than that but
you know are there key ideas that come
down to us from the Stoics or from
Aristotle or you know from from others
and then they they wind up becoming
central fixtures once people rework them
yeah and there's some coming from
Christianity too
here's a question from Stephen mcfame
not a philosophy question what's my
favorite heavy metal album that is a
very very tough one I have a hard time
coming up with favorites for even bands
if you were to ask me when I was a young
man I would have said unquestioning
unquestioningly Iron Maiden and they
really are one of my favorite bands
still but they're in that class if I had
to like you know come up with like a top
five Judas Priest and Motorhead would be
in there too
and I know that if I can if I could say
Black Sabbath and it not just be Aussie
Black Sabbath could also include do and
Ian Gillan and Glenn Hughes and you know
all the other iterations of it Tony what
was his name Tony something or other
then I would include Black Sabbath in
there and then who would be the fifth
that is a really tough one maybe rat or
maybe tank or maybe Raven or you know
I'd have to pick but when it comes to an
album oh and I don't I don't know how I
would possibly pick an album I know I
could do it so all right Gabriel Connor
how do you view the latter part of
Heidegger's work so I would actually say
that I've you Heidegger's work as three
things you've got the early Heidegger
stuff you've got the later Heidegger
stuff and then you've got all these
lectures that he gives in between think
about the nature lectures they take up
four volumes right and those provide
important I would say bridge points
Heidegger is too tough to begin with and
later Heidegger in some respects I think
is harder to sometimes see where he's
going with things
then some of the earlier stuff that
that's a bit more systematic I don't
really follow I mean there's some areas
where I just I'm in sort of big
disagreement with Heidegger from the
start he is somebody who I who I find a
useful dialogue partner but you know
some of the things that I would say
started in the beginning wind up
becoming accentuated later you know
another way of asking this question
would be lets say Heidegger had died in
nineteen you know 38 or something
what would we make of his legacy then
you know and we could compare them to
one of his contemporaries who did in
fact die quite young mock Schaller you
know how let's say Schaller lived
another 20 years would he have had had a
Kara or turning and he was already
having something like that anyway sami
io is the avoidance of death of ice and
he wants me to refer to stoicism here
it's not advice and such vices are
things like you know foolishness or
injustice or you know under injustice
greed or things like that
the avoidance of death yeah so the
Stoics you know a lot of people look at
the Stoics things like well the Stoics
they okay with suicide and they're not
they're actually only okay with suicide
in the case of somebody who you know it
is sort of properly functioning and
developed so Cato suicide okay from a
stoic perspective but somebody just
despairing and then then killing himself
that's not good
now the avoidance of death is what's
being asked about here should you avoid
death if you're a stoic yeah in general
you should try to keep yourself alive
not least because it allows you to keep
on you know enjoy
goods and performing duties and going on
with things you shouldn't seek out death
for its own sake but the Stoics
counseled us to be cognizant of what
what death really means it's not you
know it's not all the things that we
fear it to be so um
oh here's here's a political question or
a cultural question what I graciously
give an opinion on the Alex Jones D
platforming and what the Philosopher's
both ancient and contemporary might say
regarding this situation well I I mean I
think Alec Jones is kind of a toxic
person i I've actually you know listened
to show a few times when I've been
driving in the countryside
you know I'm scanning around just to
like do a little bit of research and I
was not impressed and you know the fact
that he sort of irresponsibly engages in
indulging conspiracy theories and then
Hawks all these these supplements of
really dubious value it seems you know
pretty suspect to me
should it be d platformed you know so
there's two things that we can say there
one is if we're talking about legally
right and this is where a lot of the
debate about it has has circled these
are private companies and they can do
what they want so like if YouTube wants
to screw me over because they suddenly
decide philosophy is no good they could
do that and there wouldn't be much legal
recourse now you know that's not the
same thing as a censorship by the
government or anything like that it is
interesting that Twitter is taking a lot
of heat for not deep platforming Alex
Jones when they do deep platform or you
know suspend many people who are doing
much less so there's there's also a
consistency issue there too right and
then there's the question of well why
did they wait until this time to do it I
think a lot of the organizations that
are doing it are not doing it out of any
sort of moral
but it probably shows a certain kind of
moral cowardice as well if you know it's
sort of like the with the Laura Ingram
stuff right you know you listen to and
and you know years and years and years
ago when she was much more reasonable
and gracious towards people I actually
used to listen to her show like back
when I was teaching in the prison but
that was a long time ago and then you
know finding out what it's like recently
I'm not surprised that that she lost
sponsors and you know you ask yourself
why do they wait until the last minute
because it's really about money for most
of these sponsors and most of these
platforms it's not really ideological
it's being it's being pushed onto them
as a hot potato that they have to deal
with because people are ideologically
opposed to them then there's the moral
question should you know what should we
do about speech along the lines of Alex
Jones Show right or to think about all
of his is Hawking this thing and that
thing and this thing and that thing and
you know there there we can start
evaluating it in specifically moral
terms should we I mean are we committed
to this sort of marketplace of ideas
this Mills Ian's concept that we should
like let everybody spout whatever we've
never really been committed to that but
you know there is a certain usefulness
to letting there be a lot of voices out
there I can't imagine wanting to spend
time listening to that other than you
know doing research but there's all
sorts of things that people listen to
that that I think are frankly a waste of
time now if I was in charge of Twitter
would ID platform him I would but I
would do it because I have D platform so
many other people for lesser stuff and I
would feel a need to be consistent about
it but I would also start looking at who
else I should be platform them and then
you know this is where I think a lot of
people take the stand that well if you
do it to Alex Jones then what about
these other people who we might lose
valuable voices from well then maybe we
need to have a case-by-case conversation
you know I I don't I don't actually know
what the solution is in that case and
I'm not gonna be listened to
right so William Nelson how does Aquinas
is unmoved mover argument not contradict
free will if free will to be truly free
wouldn't it have to be unmoved well
Thomas has an answer to this I mean you
can read around in the Summa just you
know actually did a Google search on
Thomas secondary causes and the answer
to that should come up for you you know
he's not saying that the unmoved mover
moves every single thing in every
determinate circumstance he's just
saying that it gets everything going DL
is God Emperor Trump the second coming
you know well hopefully he's not gonna
turn into a god emperor in the Dune way
a giant sand worm or anything like that
I would hate to have another you know
millennium of Trump not just you know I
not only disagree with him on a lot of
policy matters and a lot of the
Republicans in general on quite a few
policy matters but I just find the guy
to be you know he has a lot of vices
there's a lot of things that that speak
against having him as our representative
that said you know there are there other
people who who don't have those vices I
mean there are there many other people
who do have those vices who are on you
know politics up on the other side yes
but if we're talking about Trump he
seems to concentrate them oh here we go
here's an interesting one from we just
just scrolled suddenly looks like
there's a lot of back-and-forth between
people it was about yeah chronological
fashion Oh first first from Mohammed
what do I have to read before going to
VidCon Stein's tracked honest I couldn't
have seen at least well I think a lot of
the readers of the constraints
were frankly puzzled bite and the fact
that Russell Russell allowed him to
count that as his PhD dissertation
because truly you know amazing in an
example of academic nepotism that that
you should never allow to fly right so
yeah so the track tightest right I say
what would be useful to read to prepare
to study yeah I mean it would it might
actually be useful and I don't usually
suggest this but in the case of Vic and
Stein you know reading ray monk's
biography a Vidkun Stein could actually
be quite useful in that respect so that
would be that would be a work because it
helps give you a little bit of context I
would say you know another thing that
would be good to take a look at would be
Russell's philosophy of logical atomism
fiction Stein isn't doing exactly the
same thing as Russell was in that work
but there they're all part of a similar
let's call it family of projects
[Music]
couldn't hurt to to look at although
it's it's a later you know somewhat
later work heirs language truth and
logic to give you an idea about you know
what the logical positivists were
talking about that might be useful as
well yeah all right noha noha noha
should philosophy be read in a
chronological fashion social can't be
read before Schopenhauer and
Schopenhauer before Nietzsche you know I
would say no you don't need to read
philosophy in a chronological order but
you sooner or later want to get some
sort of idea about how things are in
fact related to each other all right so
you don't need to you don't need to read
all your way through Plato and Aristotle
before reading the stuff
for example or reading Cicero you know
and his discussions of Epicureans
academics and Stoics and sometimes
Aristotelians but you you do want to
sooner or later figure out what their
their connections are with each other
and then you'll probably want to go back
right so let's say you read Schopenhauer
and you you puzzle your way through
world as will and representation which
is quite a task to do and then you're
like man some of this I get and some of
this I don't all these references to
Kant what the hell is he talking about
well you go back and you read the Khan
and that that'll probably help right but
you don't have to read all of cat before
a reading Schopenhauer Daniel Cox if
there are things that don't get
conceptualized for Hegel walking or
brushing teeth how is this not in
conflict with the idealist thesis that
thought and being coincide well thought
and being don't coincide for Hegel I
mean reading the phenomenology and
you'll see that they're almost always
out of out of coincidence with each
other there's a continual process but I
think we're getting hung up on the word
conceptualized concept for Hegel is a
very distinct meaning so if you're using
conceptualize in the sense of just have
a notion or or an idea or a picture in
your mind of that's not quite what Hegel
means that's for Stalin
right so you know and and some things
are much more trivial than others Hegel
doesn't care much about trivial actions
quite frankly
Darkstar
how can someone avoid niall ism while
being an adherent of Nietzsche's work
well and each is an opponent of of
nihilism isn't he so if you're really
reading through Nietzsche's work he sees
Neil ISM is the great danger of our late
modern era and he criticizes it at a
number of points well you know
explaining what he thinks it is so this
is kind of a you know
in a way it's a you need to go back and
read more niche sort of answer he he
views Neil ISM is a real central problem
Heidegger by the way I mentioned those
Nietzsche lectures Heidegger takes that
as one of Nietzsche's central
preoccupations so that's that's good
Franco but of course Trump is the
political Messiah incarnate I guess he
is for some people you know I mean
that's that's the interesting thing is
seeing all these people who I thought
were principled conservatives line up
behind the guy and abandoned their their
principles and abandoned consistency and
abandoned all these other sort of
standards that they seem to have
endorsed to essentially belong to
something that's like a cult of
personality on the one hand and a let
screw over the other side mentality on
the other hand brings out you know
something bad in human nature so if he's
a messiah he's a pretty weird kind of
Messiah yeah Daniel do you believe Jesus
was literally resurrected from the dead
yeah actually I do but you know there do
I know exactly what the hell that's
supposed to mean no and you know people
have asked me about these sort of things
before I grew up Catholic left the
church came back through studying
philosophy particularly Ansem and then
through engagement and practice and you
know nowadays you could say that I'm
somebody who doesn't struggle so much
with beliefs but struggles much more
with actually practicing
okay I'm gonna skip down a bit there's
some back and forth about Greek Oh
interesting question from Bruno would
you say Rafael's depiction of Aristotle
pointing down towards the earth you know
in the School of Athens right and Plato
the heaven
is an accurate generalization of the two
thinkers philosophy Thanks
no you know why because Plato Plato's
world of the forms is not in the heavens
the heavens are at best a very dim image
of the the greater intelligibility of
the world of the form so in part that's
already off and you know Aristotle
himself he should be pointing like like
this because he does point at things of
this sublunar e realm but he also talks
about how the heavens work there's a
book called on the heavens right and I
know I don't work on that stuff too much
but there are some people who do an
Aristotle like many of the other
philosophers of his time including later
you know neoplatonist and the Stoics
thought that the heavens had a sort of
intelligible structure to them that you
could you could work on or learn Daniels
got another question are there any
versions of realism you find compelling
I don't usually use words like realism
because ask ten philosophers what
realism means you get ten different
answers it's one of those buzzwords I
guess you could say I'm a realist and
then I think that there are objective
moral values doesn't mean that when we
get to the level of cases that it's
always quite so clear I think that
objects exist and they're pretty much
you know along the lines that we
experientially perceive them even though
of course they're made of atoms and all
that that kind of stuff as well so I
mean if that makes me a realist and that
I'm a realist
but you know I think when people hear
realist they they expect it to be kind
of a naive everything just is the way it
is kind of business and like we end
investigation
all right sander allstar thoughts on
Foucault his astoria sysm philosophy the
subject so yeah Foucault is sort of like
to lose so you know I talked about that
at the beginning there's things that I
like about his works and then there's
things that I don't like and I don't
like too many Foucault Tian's
because they tend to be kind of joiners
thinking that he has the
answers to everything and when they
don't have the answers they just sort of
like you know say they're doing critical
analysis or stuff like that and I
usually waste all of our time
Fuko had some insights that were quite
good about you know the nature of
modernity and and the Disciplinary
complex and you know how in fact power
does sometimes get generated I think
there's a lot of really useful ideas
that he has and you know I think his
history of philosophy like in history of
sexuality is very very selective I
wouldn't rely upon that and the notion
of philosophy is a way of life you know
that that we get from Foucault but also
you know more famously from no not a new
idea many many other people throughout
the entire 20th century we're talking
about that sort of thing so they weren't
revolutionary in that way but you know
is his notion of well I'll give you one
example of something that I think is
quite good in Foucault so he wants to
say power is not just about domination
or exploitation right domination is sort
of like the critical or the past
despotic you know I exercise power on
you I force you to do something
exploitation you know Marxists were very
good at pointing out ways in which
people were being exploited Foucault
talks about a third way in which power
winds up being exerted and he calls it
subjective is a ssin no subjective and
say missing the word
and in a case the subject of power like
myself willfully or by virtue of in
participating in something else
generates information about myself or
relations of power that somebody else
can use so like when we participate in
Facebook and we give all of our data to
them we're engaging in something that we
call really had a good handle on you
know when we fill out our profiles
where we're engaging this other form of
power so I think that that's good
have your always what do you think about
human condition in relation with the
nonsense of existence well I mean I
don't think that existence itself is
nonsensical as a whole whole although
some people do you know if we think
about existentialism for example you've
got Camus saying existence is absurd
start saying something rather similar
Simone de Beauvoir saying it's neither
of those it's actually ambiguous meaning
we have to figure out what we're gonna
make of it
maurice merleau-ponty says something
similar and then Gabrielle Marcel's
saying no it's actually mysterious
there's there's a possibility of meaning
there but we really have to work at it
and I think left chest off is saying
something quite similar as well so I
don't think that that you know existence
is by itself nonsense but there's a lot
of nonsense we have to deal with and
sometimes when we say nonsense we mean
stuff we really can't understand and
sometimes we're using nonsense is sort
of as a synonym for you know random
[ __ ] that we have to endure because
people are you know stupid or or out to
get us or we're caught up in some sort
of system and you know the human
condition sooner or later we have to
realize that as social creatures we're
always going we have to deal with quite
a bit of other people having dictated
things ahead of time and we don't really
like it so how do we how do we adapt
ourselves to that how do we how do we
make sense of that for ourselves that's
a big question for us to to address and
pace up to Lionel Daniel what's a good
book to read to get into philosophy I
mean I I would start with Plato's
apology that's where he I usually start
students and then reads more Plato and
then move on from there I think the
annuals got another question if you want
if you had to do another PhD what school
would you like to go to and what
supervisor would you like to have a
if I had to do another PhD better put if
I was unable to do another PhD if I was
lucky enough to get to do another PhD
what school would you like to go to I
don't know I would you know I would have
to think about what I actually wanted to
get another PhD in and I'm somebody
who's got so many interests that it
would be quite a sifting process to
decide first of all what field do I want
to study I mean if I was in the
condition where I could actually go get
another PhD I would have to be like
independently wealthy right so then I
wouldn't really care about whether I'm
gonna get hired or not if I was getting
worried about whether I was gonna get
hired I'd want to go to a top-tier place
I learned that lesson the hard way all
right
I had to sort of make up for a lack of
you know distinguished pedigree by
publishing a lot and really busting my
hump proverbially so I don't know I mean
are there people I'd like to study with
you know there's a few but I don't know
that studying with them would actually
be that that great you know and a lot of
what you do as a PhD is pretty self
directed anyway so
chardee do you have any opinion on nick
land and acceleration ISM I've heard
you're not fond of it but I haven't seen
you talk about anywhere yeah I'm not
fond of it because I don't know much
about it cuz I haven't read Nick land
you know and I haven't talked it talked
about it I mean I do talk about it
because people ask me questions about it
every single AMA that I do but I haven't
gotten around to it if people want me to
read Nick land they can mail me the
books you know and then I'll try to make
the time in my very busy schedule but I
mean I'm not on top of a lot of
contemporary philosophy nobody nobody
can be there's so much stuff being
generated all the time that it's it's
tough to read everybody so alright
let's see here Bruno what are some
relationships between art and philosophy
well again it goes all the way back to
Plato right Plato had an antagonistic
relationship with artists and poets but
he himself was also one of the you know
best literary writers of the ancient
world and his his dialogues contain
quite a lot of artistry don't they I
mean you know we have play or Aristotle
discussing art in in various things and
and this is actually a question that I'm
going to have to address quite a bit in
my my ad class as I mentioned I'm going
to be teaching at the Milwaukee
Institute of Art Design this coming
semester teaching a philosophies of
human nature course so these are all Art
and Design students these are not even
humanities students this is a humanities
elective that they're taking because it
will hopefully inform their practice as
art as you know mostly visual but some
other artists and designers so we're
gonna be discussing that quite a bit
20:46 what do you think about the
priority of a distinction between the
right over the good I think right and
good I'm Aristotelian in this sense I
think right and good or both modalities
of the same sort of you know general
panoply of moral values and I don't I
don't you know make a rigid distinction
between the two of them the greeter I'm
interested in the branch that is
concerned with how to live your life
like you dye ammonia stoical views on it
or Pascal in your newest video any works
you suggest for this this branch so
ethics right ethics and other value
fields you also got to know a little bit
of epistemology and metaphysics I think
to make that work well well you know
start with ancient philosophy reading
some Plato you get a lot of that in
there some Aristotle you know nickim
mckay and ethics politics rhetoric read
the Stoics read the Epicureans what we
have them read Cicero a lot of
discussion of that in Cicero and then
you know see where you can go from from
the
and that'll keep you pretty pretty busy
for a while
Sani what's your views of the concept of
you being the universe Alan watt ISM and
other Buddhists pantheism not a
pantheist but even if I was I wouldn't
think that I'm the whole universe I
would think that I'm just a part of the
the whole of the universe in that case
right
Franco your critique on the infallible
dr. Jordan Peterson positives or
negatives again another person I get
asked about all the time and my sort of
standard take is that Peterson really
happened to be in the right place at the
right time and said things that a lot of
people wanted to hear but I don't think
that you know I think it is is work you
know I looked around in maps of meaning
I was not impressed with it haven't read
the new book I just haven't gotten to it
yet I think that he's become a prisoner
of his own success in in ways that are
gonna hold him back but a lot of people
are you know like that sort of thing so
[Music]
August deneece are there any modern
philosophers to look out for the past
we've had a Const Hegel's Aristotle's I
don't see any today almost a low period
Jurgen Habermas
kind of a famous guy plays a big role
and in the EU and you know had a
dialogue with the the previous Pope you
know I mean I think he when he was
Ratzinger Alastair MacIntyre still
chugging away at Notre Dame just came
out with a new book you know there's
lots and lots and lots of major
philosophers making major contributions
you know Martha Nussbaum just down in
Chicago although I'm a much bigger fan
of Julia honest quite frankly when it
comes to ancient philosophy and then her
and we could go on and on and on so yeah
there's plenty of people out there
another person who you probably find
really interesting who I think is quite
readable
is Giorgio Agamben refers a lot back to
refers back a lot sorry to ancient and
medieval philosophy and early modern
philosophy but he's thinking out some of
the problems of the present
here's one from brewmaster happy
birthday and thanks for this great
channel it's very nice of you to say
glad that you you enjoy it
all right people are going back and
forth about Jordan Peterson here's a
question from pro-pro poem do you think
it's important philosophy should focus
on being accessible yes I think that's
one of the great problems of
contemporary philosophy and I think it's
been a major issue for a philosophy for
the last 70 80 years as a matter of fact
there was a kind of elitism that really
screwed us over in philosophy where
people would like say oh you know
philosophy is not really good for
anything you you don't want to get
involved in this sort of thing it's sort
of like you know a lot of followers of
Vic and Stein were like that they would
they try to present philosophy is this
this abstruse thing that couldn't
possibly have any rigorous relation to
life
thank God there were other people who
weren't buying into that at the time but
that you know then when of course when
people are like well why should we pay
for this why should philosophy
departments exist they they didn't have
much of an answer other than Oh critical
thinking you know but you got to be able
to demonstrate what what critical
thinking is and that you're actually
promoting it in your students so yeah
focusing on being accessible very very
important if we want
I'm not saying water things down or you
know get rid of any rigor let alone you
know subjected to like a vote or
something like that but it is important
you and you can actually communicate in
an effective way without losing the
fullness of what's being taught I mean I
do get some criticism from time to time
where people are like well the stuff
that you know you
put out is to beginner level well yeah
because I'm you know trying to present
things to two people in a non-academic
way much of the time because there's
limits of time and I want to produce
resources that help the most people
um Lucas can I say two words about what
you think about personal identity well I
can't do it in two words but yeah
personal identity there you know we can
think about like what is personal
identity you know then we like look at
you know play-doh parts of the soul or
the Stoics or John Locke and memory and
and then we bring in you know movies
like the Blade Runner right so there
were talking about it what sort of big
picture stuff but there's also the the
more down-to-earth question that people
ask themselves well who the hell am I
you know and how do i how do I know that
my self image actually matches who I
think I am well no it wouldn't matter
who you think you are does it matter who
you actually are
and those those are much more important
questions I think it's it's good to have
the theories of personal identity what
it is it makes a person a person and
what makes them who they are over time
but it's also important to give people
tools for figuring out the nuts and
bolts of who the hell they are and
whether you know the parts that they
want to change or the parts that they
want to retain Sahni his street art a
form of rebellion and should be
celebrated in conjunction with modern
traditional art some of it might be I'm
not exactly I mean are we talking about
like stuff that's chalked on a sidewalk
or people doing performance arts you
know I don't know how much modern
traditional art is actually celebrated
Andrew yes are you aware of the theory
Alex Jones is actually Bill Hicks no I I
don't have any idea because I don't
worry about that sort
stuff too much there's not enough time
VIN kiyose Oliveira say hi to Brazil
we're watching you now at school very
cool so that that's nice I actually have
a few contacts down in Brazil and it's a
place I'd like to go sometime the you
know I understand things are in kind of
a model in terms of the educational
system which is unfortunate but we are
in one up here too
oh here's one awful philosophy what do
you is the most interesting or useful
thing about hiding your thought if I had
to pick one thing it would be the fact
that effectivity plays a central role in
our cognition of things that it's
unavoidable and inescapable and that
it's not just something irrational but
can be revelatory of being and our
condition so Franco asked right there's
no earth sensor there's no consistency
on YouTube or Facebook or any of these
social media platforms yeah there there
there is none I think they're just sort
of trying to stay out of trouble
themselves they want to try to have
things both ways where they're a private
company and yet they're also like you
know of world central importance sooner
or later I think we'll probably start to
move towards seeing them as something
like public utilities but I think we're
still a good ways from that right now
Jesse wants to get it wants to argue
that Laura Ingraham pointed out whites
are becoming a minority in America
what's unreasonable about that now you
know that's that's not all she said or
did so that's a non-starter right there
and like I said I used to be you know
actually somebody who liked her quite a
bit but she's really changed and and
it's important to acknowledge that ah
sorry I need to get into classical
existentialism where do I start
so I would say I would pick five
really existentialists Kierkegaard of
course right so fear and trembling is a
really good one
sickness onto death I think try to make
sense out of those Dostoevsky the notes
from the underground you want to read
that and actually my favorite Dostoevsky
novel is not Brothers Karamazov law for
crime and punishment it's the possessor
the demons and I think that one could
actually be quite useful then of course
Nietzsche and with Nietzsche you know
read the birth of tragedy read the spoke
zarathustra and read the genealogy of
morals then Lab chest off livestock is
one of the the earliest people besides
geared Grandes to recognize the
connections between these people that
were going to call excist Angelus and
chef stuff has a very early book on
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky which you can
you can find he also has all things are
possible great book he is not systematic
but he's very well with reading and then
read Rilke and I would read you know
real cows letters to a young poet and
then start reading around in his poetry
and read the notebooks of malte Lawrence
briga and if you do that then later on
you can go to these other thinkers like
Heidegger and yah Spurs and you know
Ortega y Gasset and Sartre and and you
know come move and all that because in
some ways that you need to get a good
basis in the early stuff so all right
Pullman writes mass media has never been
the friend of reason that's quite true
Darkstar what are the philosophical
arguments against the free speech
absolutist position III don't know what
the free speech absolutist position
actually is maybe that all speech ought
to be protected as free speech or
something like that and what would be
the philosophical arguments well some
some speech clearly is just aimed at
deception you know you want to call that
free speech or some you know there could
be cases where exercise of one person's
free speech because of the way in which
they do it like the massive megaphone
drowns out other people's for you so
there's myriad arguments out there I
answer the question about the lose early
on already Nathan asked is there a
reasonably priced resource that I know
of for learning Greek other than things
like college courses I don't because I
took my Greek years ago and I did it as
a college course I'm sure there's
probably teach yourself Greek you know
platforms out there that you could use
so yeah alright Franco methinks the
cynics of ancient Greece would support
Alex Jones although the bad taste in
their mouth I don't think they'd support
them I think they'd look at them and be
like wow all of you are crazy but this
guy is really crazy you know I don't
think there's anything about Alex Jones
that the early cynics and if we actually
think about you know what they they in
fact conceived of their role as I don't
think there's anything and that they
would find particularly attractive about
him of course they wouldn't find much
attractive about other stuff number of
other things so I'm not gonna be able to
get to all the the questions it looks
like but I'm gonna try to get to as many
as I can and the eight minutes remaining
because I do have to end on time today
all right so let's see what we got here
Pedro when developing a relationship how
do you deal with what comes off is in
consensus inconsistencies between your
values and the other person's values in
regard to commitment without absolutely
obliterating it so what we're talking
about here is less inconsistencies and
mark conflicts right between your values
and the other person's values about what
commitment means I'd say that part of it
is you have to be able to talk about it
that's tough and sometimes people can be
deceptive about that especially at the
beginning of relationships when they
want to get into a relationship right
they may tell you things that aren't
quite true
and then now inconsistency is a good
term there because you look at their
their behavior you say you're not really
behaving like a person who's committed
even though you give lip service to
commitment I think in cases like that
one thing is any any relationship with
with very you know few exceptions
particular family relationships you know
or you know one once you've made some
sort of big big big commitment you
really should be able to say okay if
this doesn't work out and and I can't
have the values that I think are
important honoured provided you made
sure that those are genuine values be
ready to walk away from it and then you
know communicate with the person
communicate what it is that you you're
looking for it'll skip down a bit some
of these are kind of repetitions of
other ones all right Gabriel I know
you're an an some specialist with other
theologians from any era who you're also
interested in besides Augustine and
Aquinas I mean it depends on what you
call a theologian John Cassian
definitely right monastic the illusion
he's somebody who Anselm read Clement of
Alexandria I'm a big fan of his
who else you know a lot of the people
that I particularly pay attention to are
philosophers rather than theologians
like Justin Martyr or Locke toxeus
so you know Bowie feeis is a philosopher
too although I mean you could call him a
theologian in a sense
yeah they aren't to help a lot of
theologians that I I really spend time
reading alright um let's see
let me just skip down a bit a lot of
these are not things I can knock out
fairly quickly well here's one I can
answer quickly well I do some videos on
the question concerning technology by
Heidegger I already did a while back you
can find them in my existentialism
playlist or look in the the Kierkegaard
playlist as well here's another
interesting one fruiting body reviews do
you think colonialism or imperialism is
something humans would always actuate
given enough time or was it more of a
perfect storm I suspect that it's so
there's a big big question right is this
something sort of inherent in human
nature yes unless we learn lessons and
we make sure that those lessons are
actually they remain learned which means
teaching them generation after
generation after generation and we do a
pretty crap job of that I mean the fact
that we're still you know we're
confronting a really wild political
situation right now in terms of you know
where human beings are going we're you
know we've managed to start screwing up
the you know the planet pretty pretty
severely there's no political will to
change that but even more so we have the
issue of AI automation logistics all
these things they're going to put
massive amounts of people out of work
and we have to figure out what the hell
are we gonna do about that and here in
our country our politicians on both
sides just have the same word over and
over again jobs jobs jobs jobs jobs
we're gonna create jobs but
work so we have to transform our
thinking and not just in terms of some
elites you know coming up with some cool
ideas that they go to Ted you know talks
about and you know try to hopefully
trickle down no we have to we we need to
actually change consciousness across
vast swaths of the population and I
don't know how the hell that happens
with all the the nonsense that that gets
you know chattered by all the other
people who have an investment in making
sure that we're talking about other
stuff instead so you know if we have new
circumstances well we have new forms of
colonialism and imperialism probably so
yeah unless we learn some some new ideas
oh here's a good one to end up on by
August do I think people start learning
philosophy too late my first exposure
was in college but could we start
learning it in middle school in high
school
yes we could indeed but it would take
having good teachers and a lot of the
times the people that we have as
teachers not just in K through 12
education but also in college are not
very good teachers not very good in the
sense of being good at their task
understanding what education is really
about some of them are not even morally
good you know they can be lazy and so
you know they can introduce you to ideas
like my first philosophy class was
actually in in high school and if that's
the only philosophy class I would have
had they would have turned me off of
philosophy for good because the teacher
was he was dry as hell
he had his particular way he wanted you
to get you know regurgitate answers on
the test and if he didn't do that then
you didn't score points and so I hated
that you know and I think many of you
would probably hate to write but
fortunately I encountered some some
other people who turned me on to other
ways of looking at philosophy
it never is too late though so this is a
great thing to end on you can be in your
40s and encountering philosophy for the
first time and you may
say oh man I wish I would have read this
when I was younger I wish I would have
encountered this in school and that's
true there you know things could have
been different and that would have been
good for you too to have had those
opportunities but you have the
opportunity now we live in a time when
we have amazing resources available you
can get almost you know the whole
history of philosophy if not completely
free very cheap compared to any other
time in history you can access it over
the Internet there are so many resources
out there to help people study and
understand philosophy there's so many
chances to be involved with other people
who are interested in the sorts of
things that you're interested in largely
because of this thing that we call the
Internet you know which has permeated
our entire existence so it's never too
late to start studying philosophy the
other thing is you'll never get to the
end of it you'll never master it it's
not possible to read everybody let alone
understand everybody let alone master
their works but that's not the criteria
the criteria is what you're getting on
and whether you're finding some some
fulfillment in learning interesting
ideas and then perhaps even being able
to apply them to your own life or your
relationships or thinking back over your
own experience or your your culture and
your society and your political
situation so that's a great thing to end
on thanks to everybody for for showing
up and I'm sorry I didn't get to all the
questions normally like I said I would
go over time but I have a lunch
appointment or from my birthday with
somebody who came in from out of town so
have a great rest of the weekend and I'm
going to end this here